um thank you for your time and that high
pollution sponsor in this case United
Airlines the main sponsor of the event
so you won't be surprised any protesters
from just up oil show up what plans do
you have in place for that
well we're hoping today is another
wonderful day in uh London we think
record is going to be broken today 1.5
million people celebrating pride in
London but this is also a day where we
celebrate the progress made in relation
to laws to protect this community equal
marriage 20 years since section 28 was
abolished but also this community
recognizing things aren't perfect
there's more work to be done to ensure
this community it doesn't face
discrimination Prejudice hatred and uh
violence and I'd hope groups like Justin
Boyle and others who want to protest
against a parade that's a celebration
and a protest will reflect whether
they're helping the cause and
encouraging more people to feel
passionate about tackling climate change
or whether they'll inadvertently drive
people away
so what plans then do you have in place
if they do show up to oppose the high
pollution sponsor that I mentioned
well there's there's always a big police
presence at pride in London uh parades
both police officers uh you know
beautiful plain close police officers as
well the key thing when it comes to
protests in my view is it should be
peaceful safe and uh lawful actually
pride in London uh the 600 groups
marching in the parade more than 35 000
people on the parade themselves are
protesting at the fact that things are
perfect in uh London particularly when
it comes to the trans Community who face
stigma stabilization demonization and
have been weaponized in a culture War so
the irony where people on a protest
could have protest against them isn't
lost on members of this wonderful
community
about other issues that are certainly
proven to be very high on the agenda for
londoners and of course anyone who lives
and work around the capital this is
Euless the expansion of eulers do you
think you're winning the arguments or
not
well it's really important people to
understand the reasons why we're
bringing in the old flow emission Zone
to all of uh London is a difficult
choice for me to make but it's the right
thing to do why because each year across
our city around 4 000 people die
prematurely because of air pollution
across the country according to the
government's own figures around 36 000
people we know the US works because in
central London and we've seen a
reduction by almost 50 percent of
toxicity a third for your children being
admitted in hospital because of asper in
inner London we've already expanded a
further fifth uh reduction so here's the
choice
do we want those five million people
living in outer London to also breathe
cleaner air or should we write them off
because they're poorer living in outer
London they tend boroughs with the worst
air quality is in Alta at London the GPS
80 of GPS with the largest numbers of
asthma patients that were all in out of
London I think you know clean air should
be a human right not a privilege
what about those businesses some of them
very small businesses who say the costs
are crippling particularly at a time of
cost of living crisis when they're
saying we simply cannot afford this
yeah we've been listening to these uh
businesses but also families local
families who have said similar things
what we've done over the last two weeks
is massively widened the eligibility for
those who can get support from tfl so
now every single business in London uh
that employs up to 50 people that's 99
of businesses are eligible for uh
support but every family in London that
receives child benefit that's more than
860 000 families will now be able to
receive support but also every charity
in London can get support not for just
one vehicle but for three of their
vehicles we are listening to the
concerns people are racing but listen
the choice is this do we you know refuse
to take action do we delay taking action
or do we take action to improve the
quality of air in London I think it's
important to take action
and I can see a lot of activity going on
there behind you just tell us about the
highlights of today what should we be
looking out for at the event
thinking about today is not simply the
lgbtqi plus Community celebrating the
progress uh made but also campaigning
for change but it's the Allies we've got
a big role to play to support this uh
Community I'm really proud to be mayor
of the in my view greatest city in the
world but also the our diversity is a
strength today weakness so the parade is
a maintenance takes place all day
Trivago Square events taking place all
day big surprise which I can reveal it's
not a surprise anymore Adam Lambert is
going to be singing in Trivago Square
tens of thousands of people in provider
Square in and around at the center of
our city from Soho to lesser Square
Trivago squids here in uh Park Lane we
are seen as a beacon to the rest of the
world relatively tolerate difference we
respect it we embrace it and as you can
see behind me we're celebrating it and
that includes the trans community
absolutely sounds like a packed day
there thank you very much indeed